[Musique]
mais les doigts
walter regard de ses adorables petits
monstres vont hausser à orlando
vous allez à la foire du mal pas vrai
dit julie demander des autographes à
nîmes ils sont préférés scarlett
overkill si j'étais un mignon c'est pour
elle que je voudrais travailler hors du
mal le rassemblement mondial des pires
crapules aux dons pour la méchanceté et
vous un don pour la méchanceté
ce n'est ni un don ni de la méchanceté
[Musique]
monsieur fait un triomphe à celle que
nous attendons d'eux
[Applaudissements]
n'est ce pas merveilleux d'être méchant
[Musique]
c'est le cas
jusqu'à là
si vous travaillez pour moi tous vos
rêves se réaliseront respect pouvoir
nana na na na waïe ces titres sont
survoltés
je vais les calmer en leur racontant une
petite histoire territoire il était une
fois trois petits cochons
il rencontre est une grande mèche en
flou elle prie les trois petits cochons
à son service un jour les petits cochons
fierté une bêtise alors la louve donc là
si fort si fort qu'elle les ait battu
face à l'eire
[Musique]